Sagittarius A* - das ist der Name des supermassereichen
Schwarzen Lochs im Zentrum der Milchstraße.
Genau dort hat jetzt ein Astronomie-Team aus
den USA eine bisher unbekannte Struktur entdeckt:
eine rotierende Scheibe aus eher kühlem Wasserstoffgas.
Diese umgibt das Schwarze Loch im Abstand
von nur einem hundertstel Lichtjahr.
Zudem verhält sich diese Gasscheibe äußerst
merkwürdig!
Ihre Lage im Raum hat keiner so erwartet.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
In der Mitte der Milchstraße befindet sich
ein Massemonster, das eine vier-millionenfach
größere Masse hat als die Sonne.
WOW!
Und diese Masse ist auf engstem Raum zusammengepackt
- ein Schwarzes Loch also.
Sein Name: Sagittarius A*.
“Nur” 26.000 Lichtjahre ist es von uns
entfernt.
Bislang gelang es aber lediglich, heiße Gase
und Magnetfelder in der Nähe seines Ereignishorizontes
zu beobachten.
Fachleute gehen zudem davon aus, dass dieses
Massemonster über einen Strahlenjet verfügt.
Und zudem wird vermutet, dass sich jenseits
der Millionen Grad heißen Gase am Schwarzen
Loch vergleichsweise kühles Wasserstoffgas
befindet.
Doch dieses “nur” etwa 10.000 Grad heiße
Gas ist nicht so leicht aufzuspüren, denn
im Gegensatz zu dem extrem heißen Gas sendet
es keine Energie in Form starker Röntgenstrahlung
aus.
Dennoch gelang es jetzt einem US-Forschungsteam
diesem Wasserstoffgas auf die Schliche zu
kommen - und zwar durch verräterische Spektrallinien.
Diese entstehen, weil die Wasserstoffatome
durch die benachbarte intensive Strahlung
ionisiert werden.
Durch Vereinigung mit ihrem Elektron werden
sie dann wieder zu neutralen Atomen.
So entsteht eine charakteristische Linie im
Wasserstoffspektrum.
Und genau diese Spur konnte das Astronomie-Team
mit dem “Atacama Large Millimeter/submillimeter
Array” (ALMA) beobachten.
So wird die Verteilung des kühlen Wasserstoffgases
um das Schwarze Loch herum also sichtbar.
Es handelt sich um eine Scheibe, die durch
das Gas gebildet wird, und die das Schwarze
Loch umgibt.
Und zwar in der tausendfachen Entfernung der
Erde zur Sonne.
In Zahlen ausgedrückt bedeutet das einen
Abstand von nur einem hundertstel Lichtjahr.
Etwa ein Zehntel der Jupitermasse beträgt
die Masse dieser Gasscheibe.
Dazu Elena Murchikoca, die an der Studie beteiligt
war: “Wir sind die ersten, die diese Scheibe
abbilden und seine Rotation ermitteln”.
Doch die neu entdeckte Gasscheibe verhält
sich anders als es das Astronomie-Team vermutet
hatte.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Die Ausrichtung
des Wasserstoffrings stimmt mit keiner der
anderen Strukturen im galaktischen Zentrum
überein”.
Konkret ist sie gegenüber dem Orbit des nahe
gelegenen Sterns G2 um 90 Grad gekippt und
steht zudem quer zur Ebene der Milchstraße.
Gemeinsam hat sie lediglich ihre Rotation
mit anderen Sternen und Galaxien in ihrer
Nähe.
Dennoch sind noch viele Fragen offen.
Beispielsweise rätseln Fachleute weiterhin
über das Verhalten und die Struktur der Gasscheibe.
Ist der Wasserstoff gleichmäßig verteilt
oder handelt es sich um dichtere Gasklumpen,
die sich angesammelt haben und die Scheibe
bilden?
Klar ist nur, dass das Gas im Schnitt eine
Dichte von 100.000 bis einer Million Wasserstoff-Teilchen
pro Kubikzentimeter aufweist.
Das hatten die aktuellen Messungen des US-Forschungsteam
ergeben.
Aber auch eine andere Sache soll durch weitere
Beobachtungen mit ALMA und weiteren zukünftigen
Weltraumteleskopen geklärt werden.
Dazu Elena Murchikova: “Noch haben wir kein
genaues Bild davon, wie die Akkretion an einem
solchen Schwarzen Loch abläuft”.
Vor allem also die Wechselwirkungen zwischen
dem heißen Gas am Ereignishorizont von Sagittarius
A* und dem heißen kühlen Wasserstoffgas
interessiert die Experten und Expertinnen
besonders.
Schwarze Löcher könnten Leben ermöglichen.
Ein Video von Raumzeit - Vlog der Zukunft.
Anklicken, anschauen und Raumzeit abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!